I am I just woke up and I saw that all
my targets are hit
so that's a good thing you know they
thought they could trick was well they
can maybe trick me the first time but
the second time the third time fourth
time fifth time now I already caught you
I already know what you are doing and we
saw this week here that we found quite
suspicious
in the context that there was a lot of
Liquidations in this one at 26 400 all
right so what they were telling me here
is okay you've pooped from here leaving
a long week behind that I know that wigs
get filled all right so that's the first
thing
the second thing is that you've said
this week right above a massive
liquidation soon why haven't you hit it
because this is a rune for liquidity and
what they want is the Traders open lungs
here so they're gonna stop losses right
right below the week so that's going to
be in this one here and also High
leverage Traders times 50 times 100
times 150 leverage Traders
soon
so what they were doing
was basically to increase the liquidity
in this or over here that's what I told
you yesterday guys this looks like a run
for liquidity it doesn't look good
this would be a red flag for opening
lungs and I'm in short position I was
that clear and you can see this now
thank you so much again for all your
comments in the YouTube video
for all the tweets that I've been
receiving in the last 24 hours I really
appreciate it again I posted a tweet
yesterday
you can only use these videos as
Confluence don't trade based on
anybody's opinions including mine all
right what you have to try to do is gain
your own knowledge okay Master the
trading system can't be mine can be any
others I don't mind
but you have to try to master a trading
system and prepare analysis by yourself
and then with this video what you can do
you can learn all right if you want you
can you can try to learn my trading
Style
or you can use it as conference to your
charts like another indicator a right
bottom trade based on anybody's opinion
because that's gonna make you weak in
the long term that's my advice all right
you can see that they come that they
came all the way to this Zone
all the targets are made I'm good I'm
out of shorts now all right
um now what I see here sorry let me
remove all of this mess that I made here
all right what I see here is
um well I see I saw this wig and then I
thought
hmm
it's a week yeah but it's not looking
that bad why because if you check the
volume
okay
you can see that this week
has almost the same volume as this large
red candle
me here
is in my opinion I might be wrong but
what they're telling me here is that
they have no intentions to go lower
at least for now okay now if we get up
up today I'm gonna favor higher prices
why today is Friday take profit stay
well that's what I have in mind you know
they've been going short all the week
check this this was from Monday let me
find Monday
so this is from Monday right so all the
way
from Monday to Thursday what to to
Friday morning in addition session
that's a nine percent
what are these guys when I take profits
from their shorts
right I think today we might see some
kind of short as quiz
and that's a little pump to the upside
all right where to
well let me first Mark the zones
um I like again I like this Scandal even
if it has a long week behind I like the
candle because the volume because it's
telling me that they are pushing price
back up
okay
you can check here
the if you try to find another another
bowling candle like that you don't want
to find it probably
okay so that's what I like about it now
could we still get the weak filled
before going higher yes why not we could
say something like this
why not
um but I don't know someone is telling
me I mean we'll go see some kind of
double information like this
okay we could see something like this
because to be honest this comes all the
way from here
I think that would be the only
the only projection valid to think that
they're gonna come back to this week
before going higher because yes they
might go higher now all right I Live
this week behind check the weekly time
frame you go to the weekly time frame
what do we have here
sorry
ah we have this long week
all right so could we be saying the same
in the one hour time frame I mean the
thing about Wix is that you don't know
when they're going to get filled
all right you can do know that they're
gonna feel so long later but you don't
know exactly when that's when you have
to find something else in the chart
that kind of help you with the timing
understood now if we Mark the zones in
the chart
let me Mark them for you this would be a
liquidity pool it's quite clear that one
let me remove these two
that's a liquidity pool
and that will be my other liquidity pool
okay so I mean if you notice
um I would say that this is pretty close
but even even this one if you want well
I buy you this one too all right so if
you think about it I would say that this
matches with the 150 I made you can see
that the chart is looking very very
extended because from here to the 50ma
in the one hour time frame these are
2.70 percent
that's quite a lot to be honest so
I don't think we're gonna go lower today
uh that's why my good feeling tells me
the instinctive film I might be wrong
but after seeing the volume in this
candle
saying that we are Reflection from one
of 150 main today's Friday they might
want to take some profits from their
shorts
and also these liquidity pools
I think today
it's not a good day to take shorts
that's my opinion again it's not
Financial advice
make your own analysis do your own
research and you can only use this as
conference if you want that's the only
thing you can do with this medium and or
try to learn okay now I want to check
is telling me
I want to go to the liquidation heat
Maps and see if we can find some
liquidity to the upside
we are in high block Capital but first I
want to see the one on time frame I want
to see how it looks like all right look
at that
thought we could triggers but come on
Market maker I know you're watching the
videos how do you expect me to believe
that I want to come back to this Zone 26
400 after you have avoided it for 300
and you push price up do you think I'm
gonna choose this Market maker come on
anyway let's check the 12 hours time
frame let's see if we can find something
interesting let's see
okay
um let's get this Zone well yes I mean I
can see that definitely hit 453 million
dollars worth of liquidations I mean you
can see very clearly here that
there are a lot of shorts open at the
moment
and they are probably gonna pay the
price because 26 700 you can see another
yellow bar and even at twenty seven
thousand two hundred twenty five
um okay let's check the seven days time
frame let's see how this looks like
let's go here
okay I see that there were some
Liquidations in the seven day sampling
too they hit them uh now in this one
here what we are right now it seems
quite um isolated soon all right you
don't see any liquidity in your buy
really
I mean you see some to the upside a 28k
but that's very far away at the moment
so you know where the traditional look
at this level for now right so this
chart is not telling me that much now
the one month time frame I don't think
that is
anything around here let's check
um not really 30k is way too far
I would say really today the most
important chart let's check the three
months time frame
I mean 25k Square close isn't it you can
say that 25 400 quite close to be honest
okay I'll tell you what I think
25 400 it's a interesting Zone I think
uh I don't think it's gonna happen
tomorrow but that's my that's my
perspective that's my opinion and then I
think the 12 hours time for Miss telling
me Kuala is telling me that there is a
lot of liquidity to the upside really
and if we check the liquidation levels
let's see here
what is
all right you can see that this chart is
very interesting I love this chat
because you can see that the moment
there is a total of 18 billion dollars
worth of short liquidations okay this is
telling me that the liquidities to the
upside right now
check this Total Source liquidations
434 total long liquidations 58. so you
can see that the ratio it's insane it's
basically telling you that one out of
nine Traders
are right now in short
possibly late shorters and they are
probably gonna pay the price so this is
what I mean if I have to choose today
what direction I favor it's to the
upside is to me it's clear right check
all these liquidations all right you
have here at 27 130.
a lot of liquidity 72 million all right
with only
shorts in time in leverage times 25
right but then if you see I mean check
the right the chart to the right where
are the spikes the spikes means you know
if you see a bigger Spike that means
that that zone has a lot of Liquidations
in that zone so where do you see all
those Spike you see them to the upside
all right
it's not looking good for shorting now
guys the same as I've been telling you
for quite some time this week now I was
favoring lower prices and I was jumping
into shorts now I can tell you that I'm
traveling higher prices at the moment
because I think that all these traders
that are sorting late
right I was late I mean at 26 526 800.
they haven't taken profit yet
because
your name look at this you see all this
Spike here this cumulative liquidations
this is packed here all right this Zone
here
that's because late shorters you can see
that jumps from
15 billion to almost 20 billion now
that's 5 billion worth of liquidations
of late shorters
that's what I think let's check it
I mean let's see this song all right
zoom in
um yes I mean look at this you see all
these circles these are
um basically telling you that a lot of
liquidations are in this um check this
out uh 27
000 26 500 26 300. these guys are going
to pay their price
for opening shorts late all right
because this is what the retail Trader
does the retail Trader is programmed
to open positions
when price is going into that direction
okay that's called fomo if it goes up
then when I say this is going to 50K if
it goes down they're gonna say okay this
is gonna go to 20K so they're gonna
start to open shorts you've seen it with
your own eyes in this chart all right
back to bitcoin again guys I don't have
a crystal ball okay all I follow is the
liquidity and also the market make it is
subscribe to the channel and watches all
the videos but anyway I'm just telling
you that I might be wrong this time okay
it's you know it's quite a risky
okay I'm saying yes I'm saying that I
don't think we're gonna go lower from
here in the short term and I think that
it's likely that we should assort the
squeeze to the upside
that's what I'm trying to say here and I
know it's risky because yes I could have
said that
anywhere in here
okay
but guess what
I didn't because they always left weeks
behind Okay you can say it wakes all the
time
I will be very happy if we can do some
kind of double Reformation here we can
then go higher okay that would be the
perfect setup in my opinion
quickly sweep the lows something like
this
of course yes why not they could sweep
this lows too okay now these are the
liquidity pools let's do this more
neatly
the quality pool
and I like this in blue okay
and let's copy this
so the chart looks cleaner okay and now
if we Mark the sessions you can see that
AC are dumped
okay that was Asia
now now it is a turn for London the
European system and you can see that
they are holding at the moment
okay so if they hold in this Zone over
here
in this box
we could expect New York
to do this okay may we know all their
way to 27k but let's mark it for now
let's see
I want this box
okay
um this is looking too messy hang on let
me remove this liquidity pool for now I
think it's clear that we have liquidity
to the website now these are my boxes
for today
okay yes we have a week here
that's your 50 at 100 of the week uh
what I would love to see is London
holding this on here
hang on London holding in this box here
even if they already do the job and they
fill the week or they sweep the lows
fantastic all right and then New York to
a star recovering and retracing this
liquidity pools over here
so that's what I think guys I think that
this at this point is more likely that
we see a short squeeze all right
remember that I don't trade on Saturdays
or Sundays I don't trade on weekends so
I would like to see this happening today
now if today we see Sideways from here
okay then we'll talk about this the next
week
let's see how the liquidation start
let's see people have taken profits but
otherwise what I still want to expect a
shorter squeeze most likely thing is
that happens today in my opinion
let's see what what happens also by the
way you can see here massive resistance
look at that so I don't think I think
like New York if if today we see a real
short squeeze okay we're talking here
about
uh two and a half percent move that's
quite big for Bitcoin to be honest now
if we see a New York if we see New York
going up
this one here is going to be the major
resistance you can see so we are gonna
close the trade before we get in there
all right
that's what I think guys
I hope that was clear uh again we don't
necessarily need to fill this week
today maybe before I saw the screw them
I leave this week for the future okay
and then come back to it like the
potential work in the the potential week
in the weekly time frame why not they
might feel it at some point too that
week at 20K why not I can't discard it
they've been feeling weaks all the time
why not R1
that's what I think
um but yes we might see
London hole in this Zone and then you
can expect New York to push or you could
see the same but also with the change of
aldoom first to fill this week or even
sweep the lows quickly and then recover
it right look over that soon so that's
what I think guys I hope that was clear
you know I try to be
neutral I don't have any bias if I was
told you you've seen it I'm improving
with YouTube channel and I don't care if
it can go so far down because I'm gonna
trade it both ways
all right and I'm also trying always
because what I do is in these videos
really is what I do in my daily in my
with my daily routine you know I'm just
doing the same but I'm just filming it
because I need to try to find a
direction and a setup for my trades
so that's why I always try to be as
clear as possible and I own and I'm not
gonna tell you price can go up or down
no I've been telling you this week price
is possibly gonna go down
and I'm telling you I think price is
gonna go up so it's quite clear
because it's also for my own three it's
just as simple as that
most Traders well a lot of YouTubers and
they're gonna tell you yes Pressman we
do this but uh 25
um be careful be careful no I'm telling
you what I think because I know that you
guys are adults
and you shouldn't
take what I say as a confirmation okay
so if you are thinking
um I got foreign
no guys that's not how this game works
all right give that in mind so anyway
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon